did you watch uh euphoria
yeah damn oh my god you walk back in
holy [ __ ] the whole the whole show i'm
like i want plot i want i stopped doing
these artsy ass montages it's boring
they said shut the [ __ ] up
your ass yeah
put a sock in it dog yeah
and all that other [ __ ] set up for that
so perfectly
i think man
she
not not only i mean
when she killed it right like i think
some of the right god some of the
writing on that show is definitely very
corny but
yeah like just the dialogue yes he's
very lame uh yeah
um but the fact that they say [ __ ]
every third word i don't know if that's
realistic or if that's
her
so in the moment trying to make it
easier for her to like say [ __ ] yeah
when she's angry but she's just [ __ ]
a lot yeah but like that kind of threw
me off but when she was crying like when
she was basically going through those
mood swings where she'd go from like
super angry to crying yeah and the
moment that she's crying and apologizing
to her sister and her mom i i was crying
like i looking for kelsey were both like
bawling and then all of a sudden she
flips right back into angry and i was
like this is incredible yeah
absolutely everyone everyone murdered
that scene
so it's it felt it felt very real yeah
it felt very real yeah so actually
uh the woman who plays roo's mom it's
kind of crazy i it hit me
while i was re-watching the first season
um i used to
go to this open mic and she would be
there all the time no way
performing yeah should stand up oh sick
yeah the you know what's funny is that
the
the role that dominic flake plays yeah i
actually auditioned for that oh yeah no
[Music]
nah nice
a really funny story this is very early
like
this might have been [ __ ]
2012 2013.
um
i was hanging out with some
some comics and she was there and
they were friends of her and i was just
um i hadn't met her before
and but the group of us were like
having a discussion about age
and i
was just like an observer aids age oh
okay
okay
and uh
um then the baby showed up now um
sorry
this is too easy and then
like an idiot you know because i'm just
like young and stupid and she's a grown
ass woman she says something about age
and then i just stupidly go how old are
you
like
like trying to like that like that even
really mattered yeah discussion she gave
this look that was a really good
question ask a woman yeah genius
question yeah to ask a grown-ass woman
and she looked at me like excuse me and
then i was i like had a moment how old
are you look [ __ ] old
[Laughter]
it was way older than i am it hit me
sure it hit me that that's how it came
across and then my boy keenan wants to
next
he
looks at me and he's like come on bro
she wasn't gonna tell you that i was
like i don't know why
i asked that i'm just gonna go so
[ __ ] shove my head in the toilet 48
49.
why did i why did i say that it was just
so stupid
um so yeah it's second hand cringe but
no i thought a great detail about her
character was when that whole scene went
[ __ ] nuts and like as the mom
she just has to be a mom so after rue
has that whole
she just walks by jules and she goes
sorry baby yeah that was like [ __ ] dude
just like yeah yeah this happens
and it wasn't even you know
i thought
go ahead i was gonna say the whole like
you could really feel just like the
hopelessness
just that there's no solution yeah what
do you do
you can't do anything yep there's
literally nothing that you can do as a
parent in that situation that would like
defuse the situation or solve it or
anything you just kind of just sit there
and let it happen which has to be such a
weird
feeling and she like nailed that
and then uh
i don't know it got like really [ __ ]
dark at the end yeah with the morphine
and everything yeah [ __ ] jesus mm-hmm
i just felt i couldn't watch it
oh when she's injecting the [ __ ] into
her arm
if it covers over my face and all that i
can't do it yeah it's too dark
yep
yep
they definitely pulled everyone's ass
back in i was like whoa
whoa yeah whoa yeah
so we'll see how the rest of the season
goes
we'll see how she's gonna make that
money back what a [ __ ] hilarious
scene
she shows up with all the [ __ ] she stole
yeah she's just [ __ ] bugged out and
she's like
you know that was such a cold line when
that woman goes you don't seem like
someone is going to come up with ten
thousand dollars very soon
like wolf yeah and then all those like
comments about the sex trafficking stuff
and
remember oh yeah at the beginning yeah
i'll sell you to some scary people yeah
yeah yeah that's why that's why i'm
saying it got so dark because of that
and then
like giving her the morphine and taking
her clothes off i'm like [ __ ] is this
the beginning of yeah her being sold
into something yeah and then being
locked into the place i was like this is
way too dark man
i bet it was an incredible episode
mm-hmm
i mean just to go from like
like
you know
shitty high school hot tub party to that
yeah holy cause we watched both of those
episodes last night
so that back to back was just a weird
like what show is this what are we
watching yeah great job so funny when
cassie threw up and he's standing there
like there's nothing funnier than like
almost throwing up yeah people gagging
so [ __ ] funny yeah maddie
cassie what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so good
oh my god oh so i actually this reminds
me of of a comment i saw on the last
episode
someone like right when it came out
one of the uh one of the comments was
like bro
uh
[ __ ] a couple of old dudes talking
about a high school show with other high
schoolers man i missed the squat 680
days as if this episode didn't have the
funniest moment
of the whole show on it
you didn't even click on it
yeah you didn't read or yeah you didn't
listen to anything that's for sure
whatever man
also
the people who just sort of rejected as
like a show about high school like there
are other qualities about the show other
than them being in high school yeah i
agree it is
cinnamon that's what i realize when i'm
watching it's a show about an addict
i mean i mean at least her storyline
yeah
yeah but i think you know if you're
talking about you know talk about like
tv and film and stuff
this show is like definitely one of the
most
uh cinematically progressive tv shows in
a long time and
you know even if that's just like a
[ __ ] pretty bow around like a
mediocre story to you or whatever you
can't deny like watching this [ __ ] if
you have any appreciation for media
there is
it's not like it's [ __ ] riverdale
yeah which is like corny ass acting
corny ass storyline and it's shot really
lame and you're like what the [ __ ] is
this cw as [ __ ]
so
i just think
you sound ignorant my boy yeah dog
yeah oh yeah and to [ __ ] hear that
whole jared goff thing and the only
thing you're sitting there thinking is
yo talk about [ __ ] after squatting
dude yeah all right man yeah
i know
anyway yeah
you